ah
[Música]
hay muchas historias de cómo las
personas impulsan cambios como inciden
en la toma de decisiones de sus países
como alcanzan la protección de sus
derechos o como detienen legislación en
contra de sus derechos lo que es cierto
es que hoy seguimos teniendo
instituciones políticas que no nos
gustan con cuyas decisiones en muchos
casos no estamos de acuerdo
preguntemos los juntes mariana qué has
hecho para impulsar cambios hasta el día
de hoy
la buena noticia es que los avances
tecnológicos nos ofrecen sumar voces
articular demandas y construir
estrategias de incidencia mucho más
efectivas para alcanzar esa ciudadanía
justa y de derechos que deseamos van a
algunas historias en chile la película
una mujer fantástica aceleró los
trámites para la aprobación de la ley de
identidad de género ganó el oscar a
mejor película extranjera y visibilizó
aún más la lucha de las organizaciones
de la sociedad civil y de los activistas
que venían pugnando por el
reconocimiento de las personas trans en
la ley hay que decir que ya había una
iniciativa en este sentido en el
congreso de chile y que no se había
probado desde 2013 en ese entonces la
presidenta michelle bachelet le impuso
la suma urgencia al congreso chileno
para su aprobación en esta historia
tenemos a las organizaciones de la
sociedad civil y a los activistas al
cine a las instituciones a la presidenta
y al congreso pero también a toda esa
ciudadanía que desconocía el tema y con
este
la exigencia se pudo posicionar y
acompaño esa aprobación
en méxico tenemos muchas historias desde
la sociedad civil de como la tecnología
nos ha ayudado a posicionar temas y a
defender nuestras libertades en este
sentido la lucha por los derechos
digitales siempre se activa muy bien en
mexico la organiza las organizaciones
especializadas en este tema están muy
atentas a cualquier modificación que
tenga la legislación que atenta en
contra de esta libertad de internet se
llama como la batalla a favor de la
neutralidad de la red y que no es más
que el mantener el libre internet que
hoy conocemos otra historia reciente en
mexico es la aprobación de los derechos
laborales de las trabajadoras del hogar
esta lucha la encabezan las propias
trabajadoras desde una organización por
el reconocimiento de sus derechos y una
suma y una alianza de otras
organizaciones de la sociedad civil que
construyeron una estrategia de
incidencia muy efectiva
dar a conocer este tema a la ciudadanía
sensibilizarnos sobre ese tema pero
también sensibilizar a las instituciones
para lograr su aprobación
bueno ahora la mala noticia y no tan
mala es que para construir y tener otra
democracia porque la de hoy no nos gusta
se requiere de nosotros porque nunca han
habido cambios que se den de la nada
siempre los cambios se dan con personas
exigiendo detrás se trata de elegir una
batalla y de asumir una postura en esa
disputa
han pensado que elegimos personas para
que nos representen en el congreso y que
no las volvemos a ver sino hasta la
próxima elección que hicieron que
votaron los perjudicó nos convino que
estuvieran en el congreso
es como si contratas a alguien para que
lleve a cabo una labor
te convenció su currículum o fue el
menos peor y la dejas tres años sin
saber nada regresas para elegir a
alguien que le sustituya y nunca periodo
los entregados nunca supiste que hizo
pero ojo tú tampoco le exiges te los
entregables
no hay que olvidar que es fundamental
votar en las en las elecciones en
democracia es fundamental elegir a
nuestros representantes y ejercer ese
voto pero no es la única obligación que
tenemos las y los ciudadanos
y algunos dirán bueno cómo es que
podemos participar más y mejor mi
apuesta es por la tecnología cívica y
qué es la tecnología cívica son todas
estas plataformas apps
herramientas tecnológicas que nos
ofrecen información pública en lenguaje
ciudadano accesible y que no sea
complejo ni aburrido y que nos activan
nos informan nos hacen posicionarnos y
nos permiten nos dan un canal para
activarnos y para exigirle a nuestras
autoridades
bien les vengo a presentar la pac
es la plataforma de articulación
ciudadana que es un proyecto que estamos
trabajando en borde político para que
conozcas cómo es que votan las y los
legisladores en el congreso de la unión
se trata entonces a esta página
www.cndh.org.mx te informamos sobre un
tema que ya se haya votado en el
congreso te pedimos que asumas una
postura y que votes
después te mostramos cuál fue la
votación real de las y los legisladores
en el congreso
esta es la cámara de diputados y en el
senado de la república de esta forma vas
a saber como voto tu representante a ese
que elegiste para que te representara en
esta asamblea plural y democrática claro
que primero tienes que saber por quién
votas te para poder buscarlo aquí
finalmente te decimos qué partido te
representa qué tal que descubres que el
partido político por el que tú votaste
no vota como tú desearías que votar
qué pasa si descubres que otro partido
político te representa más que jamás lo
hubieras pensado o qué pasa sin ninguno
de estos partidos políticos que
representan
hicimos la paz para tener un archivo y
hacer una memoria histórica porque estos
son los nombres que seguramente vas a
ver en la boleta electoral los próximos
años debemos de dar seguimiento a las
decisiones de nuestro congreso saber que
votaron y quiénes fueron los que votaron
eso
de no existir la pac tendrías que entrar
a buscar votación por votación en las
páginas llenas de información
legislativa y jurídica de nuestros
congresos
bien
algunos dirán que la tecnología cívica
no tiene alcances para impulsar un
verdadero cambio en nuestra democracia
dada las desigualdades de nuestro país
por supuesto la brecha digital es un
problema que debemos reconocer y
solucionar
pero imaginen algo
cuando empezamos borde en 2012 nos dimos
cuenta y apostamos por la tecnología
cívica porque supimos que en ese
entonces había 50 millones de usuarios
de facebook en méxico y en ese entonces
el presidente electo los eligió por
menos de 20 millones imaginen 50
millones menos de 20 millones qué
pasaría si esas usuarias y usuarios de
redes sociales en méxico se metieran
media hora a este tipo de tecnología
cívica se enterarán de que están de qué
decisiones se están tomando nuestras
instituciones y se activarán
creemos que hoy es momento de tomar
conciencia de esto hoy es momento de
asumir nuestra responsabilidad para
hacer otro tipo de ciudadanos dada la
pandemia la pandemia no se nos ha
reflejado todas las precariedades en
todos los sentidos económicos políticos
sociales laborales y también han
revelado la fragilidad institucional de
nuestros congresos y su incapacidad para
comunicarse con nosotros es urgente que
construyamos canales efectivos de
comunicación entre nosotros
nuestros representantes a quienes
elegimos para estar ahí y representamos
les invito a reflexionar sobre nuestra
participación hasta hoy como hemos
participado en nuestra incipiente
democracia y cómo vamos a participar en
esta democracia en cuarentena que la
pandemia sea un parteaguas que no
volvamos a hacer la misma ciudadanía de
antes de la pandemia
que sea una vacuna en contra de la
apatía en contra de la queja sin
propuesta del desconocimiento de qué es
lo que hace cada institución política en
méxico
de nuestro profundo miedo a debatir y de
nuestra incapacidad a tener ese debate
franco honesto y sin descalificaciones y
reconozcamos también ese miedo profundo
a asumir posturas políticas
todas las decisiones políticas todas
afectan nuestra vida cotidiana
hagamos conciencia de ello y hagámonos
cargo
muchas gracias